حدث اليوم نتناول فيها حجم المساعدات
الغربيه لاوكرانيا وامكانيه تواصلها في ظل
بعض الاصوات الرافضه ومدى قدره كيف على
الصمود في هذه الحرب في ظل عدم الاستقرار
في تقديم الدعم لها كيف وحول هذا الموضوع
للحديث حول هذا الموضوع ضم الينا من كيف
الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه السيد قسطنطين جريدين ارحب بك سيد
قسطنطين على
فرانس فانك سابدا معك من حيث العرقله او
عرقله المعارضه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي الاربعاء بالامس طلبا قدمه البيت
الابيض لاقرار حزمه مساعدات طارئه بقيمه
106 مليارات دولار تستفيد منها بالدرجه
الاولى اوكرانيا واسرائيل بسبب عدم تضمنها
اصلاحات في مجال الهجره هذا الرفض لهذه
الحزمه من المساعدات
ما هو انعكاساته على الموقف الاوكراني
عسكريا اهلا وسهلا اولا اريد ان نقول ان
هذا الراط الذي حصل عليه
ا الحزب الديمقراطي اليوم هذا ليس راطا
نهائيا نظرا
لتوافر الوقت امام مو انتهاء جلسات
الكونغرس الامريكي قبل
اجازات الميلاد وايد راس السنه مازال هناك
وقت للتفاوض وما زال هناك كمجال للتنازلات
لان اهم النقطه التي تريد يريد حزب
الجمهوري التنازلات فيه كما نعلم هذا
مساله هي مساله الحجره ف لذلك هناك وقت
للتفاوض بين الحزبين وانا ما زلت متفاعل
بالنسبه ل فرص تبني هذه هذه القوانين نظرا
لنقطه واحده ان ولا حزب الديمقراطي ولا
حزب الجمهوري سوف يستطيع ان يستخدم فاشل
اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن النفس امام الروسيا
كعنصر في انتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله التي
نحن
نشاهد نشاهد الان بدايه
الحمله حمن حولها طيب سيد قسطنطين ما
الدور الذي قد تلعبه اوكرانيا ما الذي
يتوجب عليها
لاقناع الطرفين في الولايات المتحده سواء
كان او حتى في دول الغرب لتقديم هذه
المساعدات لتسريع هذه المساعدات رفع وتيره
هذه المساعدات
ا صراحه انا اعتقد ان مشكله ليست في
اوكرانيا نفسها لكن هذه
ا اللعبه السياسيه الداخليه نظرا
لترابط
بين مسائل دعم الاسرائيل ودعم اوكرانيا
ومساله الحدود
فاوكس
ما كان يجب عليها ان تقوم به مؤخرا هناك
وفد رفيع المستوى موجوده الان في واشنطن
فلا نعلم تفاصيل هذه المفاوضات لكنني
اعتقد
انهم يقومون يبذلون كل الجهود الممكنه
لاقناع النواب الامريكيين بمواصله الدم
وعموما اعتقد انه لا هناك مجال او ز
لاقناع لان ان فشلت اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
النفس نحن نعلم ان بوتين سوف لا يتوقف
داخل اوكرانيا وسوف يقترب
بحدود حدود
اوروبيه مما يؤدي الى ضروره استخدام
القوات الامريكيه نفسها في الدفاع عن
حلفائها في النيتو وهذا هذا ما يريد الحزب
الديمقراطي وحزب
الجمهوري تجن ب باي ثمن ممكن ولذلك انا
مازلت متفائلا بخصوص امكانيه التوافق بين
الجانبين انت متفائل سيد قسطنطين لكن هل
هناك خشيه داخل اوكرانيا لدى زيلنسكي لدى
الجيش لدى القيادات حتى لدى الشعب من ان
تراجع هذه المساعدات او التاخر في هذه
المساعدات قد يؤدي الى نتائج عكسيه او
سلبيه على الارض هل هناك
مخاوف من هذا النوع
صراحه الشعب الاوكراني الذي عاش هذه الحرب
منذ
تقريبا لمده تقريبا سنتين لا يستخدم كلمات
زي خشيه او المخاوف اوكرانيا بدات هذه
الحرب ضد روسيا بدون اي مساعدات عسكريه
ولا ماليه من الغرب
ونجحت
في وتمكنت من صد الهجومات الروسيه بدون
مساعدات الغربيه العسكريه بشكل جوهري
فلذلك مهما كان الوضع اوكرانيا تستعيد
لمواصله ال
لمواصله الحملات الدفاعيه
ومن الواضح ان لاستعاده السيطره على
الاراضي المحتله بروسيا حاليا سوف تحتاج
للمزيد من المساعدات الاسكريه وهذا ما
تحاول السلطات الاوكرانيه اقناع به ال ال
النواب والامريكيين في في هذا السياق كم
من الوقت باعتقادك سيد قسطنطين باستطاعتها
ان تواصل اوكرانيا وان تنتظر ان يتم اقرار
هذه المساعدات سواء كان من الولايات
المتحده او حتى من الاتحاد الاوروبي وساتي
على الاتحاد الاوروبي في سؤالي التالي ا
صراحه نحن يمكن ان نستخدم او
ا يعني نستخدم الشيعيات
او المعلومات المتصرفه من الجيش الاوكراني
او اطراف اخرى ولكن لا ولا احد يعرف كم
وقت تستطيع اوكرانيا ان تواصل العمليات
الدفاعيه وانا اعتقد انه نظرا لتوفر
مساعدات مساعدات معينه او
مساعدات العسكريه سوف تغير القياده
الاوكرانيه تكتيكاتها في تكتيكاتها في
المعارك وسوف تستطيع ان ان تمر بهذه
المرحله الصعبه لكن المهم هذه ال الهاتف
استراتيجي ليس دفاع عن النس فحسب بل
استعاده السيطره على الاراضي الكامله
المحتله هذا هو الهادف الذي لا يمكن ان
يتحقق بدون الدعم الامريكي طيب انت قلت
انك متفائل سيد قسطنطين لكن ايضا هناك
حديث حول ان رئيس الحكومه المجريه فيكتور
اوربان طالب بتاجيل قرارين اساسيين يخصان
اوكرانيا اولهما بالتاكيد الدعم المالي
بقيمه 50 مليار يورو والقرار الاخر كان
بشان بدء المفاوضات لانضمام اوكرانيا ال
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اي مدى هناك ايضا
مخاوف من تبدل او تغير في الموقف
الاوروبي حول الحرب في
اوكرانيا لا هناك لزوم لتغير الموقف
الاوروبي لكنه لكنه هناك ضروره لتغير موقف
المجري فانا اعتقد انه 27 دوله دوله
للاتحاد الاوروبي سوف تجد الحلول
ستمرار الضغوط
على عفوا رئيس الوزراء لكن بحاجه للموافقه
المجاريه انت تعلم ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
بحاجه لموافقه جميع الاعضاء ن
نعم نعم صحيح وحسب ما هو الحال في
الكونجرس الامريكي هناك مفاوضات وربما
تنازلات الم
مقدمه
ف اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يقوم
بمثل يعني تقديم التنازلات او
يعني المساعدات
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي للمجر لكي يغير
موقفه بالتاكيد ان رئيس الوزراء المجري
يلب نوعا ما الى جانب بوتين ولكن هناك
تواحد باقي الول الاتح الاتحاد الاوروبي
حول موضوع دعم اوكرانيا فلذلك مازلت
متفائل بهذا الموضوع ايضا نظرا ل يعني
تواحد الدول
وضروره الدفاع عن الحدود الشرقيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي كل الشكر لك سيد قسطنطين جريدين
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه كنت معنا من
العاصمه
كيف مشاهدينا فاصل قصير ونعاود التواصل
معكم وابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
n